とりあえずこれで講義終了いたしますが
時間を過ぎておりますけど
何かご質問などある方いらっしゃいましたら挙手をお願いします
はい  お釈迦様が腸が弱かった
弱く お釈迦様は前のお話で腸が弱かったというお話だったんですけれども
それはずっと修行をずっと何十年も修行してらして
そのカルマをそれだけ何か残しておいたんでしょうか
どういうことでしょうか
その阿羅漢より以上だっていうブッダとなられたわけだから
ずっと修行の途中で全部
日本語だからね 喋ってる方
全部正確に分かったから
し どうして腸が弱いっていうだけが残ったのかなと思って
あれは苦行のせいでしょう
一つは苦行のせいで もう一つはものすごいもう想像できないほど幸福で贅沢で育てられたでしょうね
28になるまで ご飯食べる時は
この壊れていない米 1粒1粒選んで
シッダ当時に米を炊いたんですよ
ご飯を そこで色が変わったものは取り出したりして
黒い色のものは取り出したりして
そこまで贅沢でしたからね
だからこれ 28まででしょうに
いきなり普通の一般人が貧しい人々が作って食べて残ったものを食べる羽目になりましたでしょうに
お腹が壊れるのは決まってるでしょう
だから疑問というのはどこかあまりピンとこなかったんですね
次の質問のポイントがわからなかった
私 お釈迦様ってすごく健康でいらして
全てが完全だったのかなという感じを持ってたものです
肉体はね 肉体はもうそうじゃないんですね
肉体は心のパワーで抑えることは簡単にできましたけど
そうなってくると仏教は成り立ちませんだからね
みんな拝むだけになるんですよ
そうじゃなくて お釈迦様もものすごい苦労したんです
だから言うことを聞きなさいということなんですよ
ご飯がもらわなかった日々も結構ありましたしね
だから人間っていうのは汚くてね
お釈迦様ほどお布施した方はいませんよ
この生命の中で なのにお釈迦様にはガチャガチャいろんなこと言ったりして
ご飯 1つぐらいはくれないというね
人間そんなもんで それでも説法はする
だからまあ 体はね 普通です
体は父親母親からできたものだからね
はい  今日の 72名で今日の 72名で
子供が何か考え事をすると
それは結局不幸になるという話なんですけども
その中には周りの人も不幸にするんだよという意味が入っていると考えてよろしいでしょうか
それは常識でね 自分だけで自分でも破壊するぞということは言わなくちゃいけないんですね
だから人を飛行機に持っていってやりば
原子爆弾を落とすのは自分が安全だよとみんな思っているでしょう
だから今もそうでしょうね
人は破壊するんですけど
自分たちが安全だと そうじゃないんですよと
いうことはわざと強調するんですよ
だから  72は自己破壊になりますよという意味だけなんですね
一応そこは強調しています
他人の破壊は当たり前で
言うまでもない それはわざわざ説法しなくてもいいということになっています
あんまりないんですよ
悪人が人に迷惑をかけますよっていうのは当たり前ですからね
人に迷惑かけるのは当たり前で
あんた一人だけ迷惑かけてるつもりでしょうかと
ひどいことあなたにもなりますよということをピンポイントするところなんですね
次に違うのは 餓鬼の生命に行って自分の罪を償って
また人間に生まれ変わってきた人がいたとしたら
その方はやっぱり罪を償ってから良い方で生まれて
生まれ変われます 変わりますよ
良い方になって  わかりませんね
結局は ものすごい因縁は長いんだからね
餓鬼が餓鬼道の悪業が終わった時は人間がいなかったらどうしますかね
地球も破壊してやったらどうしますかね
それは寿命長いんだからね
まあ不可能っていうことじゃないんです
どうしても永遠じゃなくて
永久的じゃないんだからね
どんな地獄に落ちたっても
その業が終わったら別なところに生まれるんです
しかし 地獄にいたんだから
罪を償ったんだから 次天国って
そんな順番じゃないんです
業はたくさんありますから
次どうなるかってことははっきりしません
人間でいて すぐ死後直接天国に行けない状態でしょう
人間で生まれて それで私すごく怒ってますよ
人間であると あんた方は
人間なのになんだこの思考はとか
なんだこの態度はとかね
なんだこのわがままはとかね
明確に道がもう見え見えで
これは因果法則によって言えないだけ
ギリギリのところまで人が心変えればね
予言は当たりませんだからね
でも今日あなたの生き方はもう地獄行きやってぐらいは言えます
今日のあなたの生き方はと
今日のあなたの生き方はアジビ地獄に落ちる罪だよと
そういう風には言えますけどね
まあそんなこと言ったって意味がないしね
で それ権利ないし 言う権利はないんです
他のところでガチャガチャ悪口言ったり喧嘩することをするのはそういうわけなんです
言いたいことは別にありますけど
そういう権利がないんだからね
言わないんです だからからかったり
いろいろごまかしたり
バカにしたり 普通な世界でいろいろ頑張ってはいるんです
例えばね 日本人がね なんか笑うことわかりませんよとかね
極限に暗いんだからそれ言ってますよ
だから極限に暗いっていうのは
あんた方は過去生でも
もしかすると餓鬼道から跳び上がってきたんじゃないかと言いたいんですけどね
それは言う権利はないんです
これは将来の準備でしょうと
いつでも苦しんでいるのは
いつでも暗くいるのは
今修行中やと 次の生まれ変わりに習いのためにとかね
そういう まあとにかくこのはっきり言わないで
そういう風に間接的に冗談交えてしか言うことできないけどね
だから言いたいポイントは
人間でありながら 死後天国はもう確定したものだという生き方というのは
いとも簡単にできるでしょう
ちょろいでしょうね それぐらいは
何のこともないんだよ
朝飯前とも言うまでもないんですよ
僕 普通にノーマルで生活すればね
自分の義務を果たして
よく明るくて できる範囲でね
人々の 協力してあげたり
助けてあげたりして それぐらいのことどうったことはないでしょうに
それにまあこちらでもちょこっとしたお手伝い頼んだところで
もう二 三回ぐらいやって
まあそれ嫌でやるんだから能力は上げません
向上しません 嫌でやったって得がないんだから
自分も人の役に立ったなとかね
不思議がった方がいいでしょうに
普段何もできんあれでしょうしね
こちらに来たら結構大変な仕事をね
もう立派なことをさせているのに
で これが喜ばない まあやっぱり準備中ですよ
たとえブッダに触れても
やっぱりもう何か今受験中だからね
それは本職で能力を上げない
それで二 三回やったところで
もうできない 時間がないとかね
私に向かって言うんだからね
忙しいんだからと で 私はどれぐらい仕事をしているんですかね
で やっぱり私はある面で腹が立つんです
一つはここまで仕事をさせているのに
なんでこの人は能力は向上しないのか
なんで明るくならないのか
なんで幸福にならないのかと
だから自分の悪思考はもう断言的に変えませんよという
この我の強さっていうのはすごい手強いんですよ
だから言いたいのは 人間でありながら
もうなかなかもう自分の道をね
幸福に変えられませんね
変えれません 簡単なのに
何のことなく楽しく生きていられるのに
何のことなく人の役に立つように生きていられるのに
そうやればやるほど元気になっちゃって
明るくなっちゃってね
成長するはずなのに 逆に行っちゃいますね
それで餓鬼道にいる人に
餓鬼道だったら天国やというのはね
ちょっとどうでしょうかね
だから論理的に可能性と実際にというところはね
もう我々にも皆様には日本の総理大臣になれるということは権利あるんだけど
だからってなれないでしょうに
失格というわけじゃ絶対ないでしょ
総理大臣になるために必要なのは
ただ国民であることだけでしょ
一番面白いことは このただの郵便配達員になれたっても
資格調べますよ 試験を受けなくちゃいけないんです
国を支配するならば資格はなし
そういうふうに自分の都合によって制度を作っています
いくつかの国 一つ二つだけかな
シンガポールは厳しいんです
誰でも国民だからといって選挙に出ることはできません
審査会あります そちらに出して
自分がこれぐらい財力があって
これぐらい能力があって
これぐらい人間であると
そちらで調べて調べて判子を出してくれるんです
それから選挙で あれは法律ではなくて
別に法律ですけど そちらで判子はそちらから許可を受けたという書類が必要なんです
申請する場合は 候補をする場合は
そこでかなりある人がすごい金持ちの人なの
シンガポールでこのなんかちょこっと商売でちょこちょこっと不安定なことをやった
なんとかあって それで却下されちゃったんです
あんたはちょっと危ないんだと
それほど大きい問題ではなかったんですけどね
他はないんですね だから言いたいのは
あの日本国民みんなに日本の総理大臣になれる論理的な権利はありますけど
論理的に可能ですが 実際はもう無理
不可能 これ実際というところだけなんです Practically Practically
不可能ですが theoretically
は可能です このtheoretically practical
という 2つを覚えておいた方がいいんです
甘くないんです だからどんな人間にでも悟れるということは theoretically
可能であって 人間 全ての生命は平等であるということは
theoretically平等であって tactically
は平等じゃないんです
この二つはっきりしています
状況を語る場合は その両方合わせて合わせて語らなくちゃいけないんです
なんです  theoretical の観念的なというか
観念みたいなもんですけど
なんで出すのかというのは
頑張りなさい 頑張りなさいということなんです
だから永遠な地獄はありません
永遠なものは何もないんです
だからどこかで生まれたら必ず死ぬの
死んだものは必ず生まれ変わる
避けられません まあそれだけのこと
だから餓鬼道に落ちたら
まあ寿命終わったら死にますよと
次はどこかに生まれ変わりは聞くない
知りませんよ そんなのと
しかし 生まれ変わる法則は教えてあげますよと
そんな風にしか そういう風に語るんですね
やっぱり 永遠の地獄とはおかしいでしょうにね
人間が永遠にひどい目に遭うぐらい罪は犯せませんだからね
こんな短い人生でね 例えば神を否定すると永遠の地獄があって
一番大きな罪はそれやとキリスト教でおっしゃってるでしょうに
おかしいでしょうに だってそれだったら神様の仕事で
人類みんなに自分がいることを教えてあげるのはね
一部の人間だけ内緒で秘密で教えたりしてね
それでも他の人々は別な生き方しているし
知らないし そんなアホな人に作られたっていうことさえもね
だから知らない人も永遠の地獄に落ちますかね
堂々と言ってますよ 神の福音が届いてないところはもうどうしようもないんだぞとかね
私にも一応参加してくれませんか？というメールがありましたけどね
この第3セクターで第4セクターですか
この枠の習熟やとこの仏教とかやってますよと
その人々を救わなくちゃいけないんだから
シンポジウムに参加してくださいと
2週間で 1年前でも伝道師になりますよと
行きたかったんですけど
場所が 場所は残念ながらアメリカなんですね
日本だったら本当に行きます
えっと その後ろのあのパーカーというか
さっき着られてた あの独覚仏陀というのは
先月のゲーム七十一番のエピソードでも出てきたんですが
阿羅漢とは違うんですか？あるいはその七十一番の独覚仏陀と七十二番の独覚仏陀は同一の方なのか
七十？ 七十二 先月の  ああ
ちょっと待って こちらの名前出ましたけど
まあそれはっきりわかりませんね
ストーリーの中に えっとえっと
名前入ってないんですね
これ違う方でしょうね
でもわからない  開いた方で
説法はなさらない方っていう阿羅漢
阿羅漢という最終的な到達した方とは別の
独覚仏陀も阿羅漢も正覚仏陀もね
正覚者も結局は悟ったって意味なんですけどね
まあ方法論ですね 別に中身というよりはね
阿羅漢というのはブッダから学んでもらって
弟子として合格する 独覚仏陀は一人で道を発見して悟る
正覚者は同じ一人で道を発見して悟りますけど
説法もする それだけの差ですね
テーラワーダではいうのは
だから独覚仏陀はまあただ説法しない
語りません うん 悟りについては何の差もないんです
煩悩が消えたならば煩悩が消えた
まあそれで話は終わりということになるんです
方法は違うでしょうと
方法違ってもいいんじゃないんですかね
服を洗濯する場合は これ手洗いでしたんだと
で これを洗濯機でやったんだと
これはロンドリア なんて言いますか
に頼みましたと どうでもいいでしょうに
服が綺麗になっているならば
すいません  はい  よろしいでしょうか
はいはい  人間から人間に生まれ変わるっていうのは
すごい宝くじに当たるぐらい難しくて
地獄とか餓鬼とか下の次元のアパーヤの次元から人間に来るのはまた難しいとすると
今この地球上にいる六十五億ぐらいの人間の過去生っていうのは
ひょっとしたら じゃああれなんですかね
欲界の天だった可能性が高いんですか？ うん
比率としては  まあね まあ一応
それちょっと思いわかりませんですけど
まだ私たちわからないいろいろ生命の次元もね
仏教はもう六 五道にすごいシンプルに分けてますけど
その中に微妙なものすごいたくさんあるみたいんですよ
生命次元がね それは余計なことだから説かれてないんですよ
うーん 人間の世界で見ると
まあそう思わざるを得ないケースもないわけじゃないんですね
見ると まあ別に何のことなくね
特に日本でも子供たちなんか見ると
この親の考え方をする前っていうとびっくりするほどいい子たちなんですよ
すごい力があって もう私もびっくりするぐらいすごい生命力が
オーラがというかね 則別な言葉なんですけど
パワーがあったりして
これはずっとみるみるうちに消えていきますからね
二  三週間で気づくこともできますから
人間すごいんです だからいいところから帰ったやつだなとかね
と思っちゃいますよ で
それからですね 世間のことを世間のね
競争やら憎しみ それを学びますから
あの光がどんどんどんどん減っていくんですね
だから結構いいところから上がった人やと思った方がいい
まあね 可能性としては高いと思いますね
あと時代っていうのも
日本の長い歴史の中でずっと封建時代でもう搾取されてきて
今の時代っていうのはすごい比較的自由な自由に時代的にもいいですよね
日本は  それに私には何も言えませんね
自分の国の場合は逆なんですね
どんどん悪くなっちゃうんですね
だから あまり日本の歴史はね
はっきり知らなくて 何も答えは出せません
しかし 現代の子たちもすごいだらしなく
もうなんか糸切れたような感じで生きているケースもいっぱいあるでしょう
自由なんですけど これ使い方わからないんですね
昨日買い物ヨドバシに行ったんですね
駅改札口出た途端 ものすごい品格のある
すごい決まっている若い女の子が見たんです
すごい背が高くて 服装もものすごいもう決まって
すごくかっこよかったんです
派手ではなかったんですけど
すごいシンプルで で もうおしゃれなんですけど
ものすごいシンプルで
すっごいかっこいい で
その子はもう歩き方もものすごいしっかりと背筋を伸ばして淡々と歩いていて
品格いい子だなと思ったんですね
派手なものって何一つ身につけてないんですね
すごいなんかね なんて言いますかね
すごいお嬢様らしくっていうかね
まあ服装と歩き方だけではね
それでは結構ですけど
そこであるまだ若い男の子が
またそいつもそれなりにもうかっこいい子で
なんかあの あれなんて言いますか
いろいろ商売やったり
いろんなことを言ったりとかやってるでしょ
駅でね 話しかけたりとかね
もうなんとか商売かそれはわかりませんだけど
この話しかけるんですね
その時は彼女も形だけではなくて
対応もすごい すごいしげっと
とこカチッと止めて で
話を聞いてあげたりするんですね
その時私は見たのはこのこの男の子の態度
ものすごい紳士らしく
すごい丁寧に ものすごく頭を下げて
すごい丁寧に これこれでいかがでしょうか
なんとかもう考えていただけませんでしょうかとか
もう丁寧なこと 紳士らしいこと
それで思ったのは こんなに性格いい連中なんですけど
結婚したらこれどうなるのかと
逆になるでしょうと 結婚したとこその瞬間でね
こんな男なのに こいつは結婚したところで奥さんをバカにして
何も気にしないで そういう世界だなと
ああいう風にね 結婚してから自分の奥さんをすごい丁寧にもう挨拶をして
もう生活するならばね
すごい幸せなのに それはないなと
まあ冗談で思ったんで
私ども思うことないんだからね
瞬間で ほんの瞬間の出来事で
データだけは大量に取っちゃったんです
うん  [背景音楽]だから一般的には人間っていうのはね
まあ見込みは本当にありますけどね
だから我々がこれがまずい操縦間違っちゃうんですよ
だから操縦間違うのは今世の問題でね
人間には神々よりは調子条件はいいんですよ
心変えるっていう場合はね
全部見事にすごいいいところ
あのエクイリブリアムというね
あの 何て言いますかね
全てこの一番いい条件に揃っているんです
体の状況も で 誰でも同じ細胞でできてますけど
人間の細胞のプログラムはそれなりに仲良くするし
で 体と心の関係もすごいものすごいコンディション
一番ベストコンディションでできているんですね
これ 次元変わると崩れます
だから心変える場合は
他の生命にはもうすごい無理
不可能 まあ例えば動物も我々も同じ細胞でしょ
しかし 動物の場合は心の働き管理されてますよ
あるリミットがあって
それ以外の物事は考えられないんです
で 肉体がそこは遮断しているんです
例えば犬はドアを開けられますけど
閉められませんでしょ
それは教えられませんね
いいですか さっきの先生の説法の中でもあったんですけれど
あのいい人になろうとするのを邪魔される
馬鹿にされるっていうことがあるじゃないですか
自分もやっぱりそういう傾向に悩まされてるっていうか
苦しんでるところあるんですね
職場の中で やっぱり次元の低い職場なのかもしれないんですけど
やっぱり気を使ったり
言い方丁寧にしたりとかっていう風に努めていると
気が弱いんだ 媚びてるんだっていう風に思われるらしくて
バカにされるんですよね
それでなんだこんな奴らと思ってツンケンしてたんですよ
そしたら一目置くようになって
なんだこの次元はっていう
で やっぱり自分はいい人になりたいんですよ
で その分の怒りが回転してて
ちょっと最近ままならない状態なんですね
混乱してます どうしたらいいでしょうか
うん それまだまだいい人間になれないっていうことなんです
いい人間っていうのはほとんどトラブル作りません
だから大変だと思いますけど
この あの 何といいますか
この変わる時期はね このTransition period
英語と言いますけど 変換時期
あんた方にとってはこれすごい苦しいと思いますよ
だからある日突然始まりましたからね
で 仏教の世界ではね もう物事わかるともういい人間になることはもう教えているんだから
何のこともないんですよ
後で悪いことになったっても
もうすぐ変えられます
もう怒鳴ってなんとか言ったら
もうやめろよと言ったらやめちゃいますよ
で 簡単ですけど まあその概念さえない文化ではね
いい人間になるべきというね
文化で大人になってからね
ということは 結構この変換時期は大変だと思います
いい人間になったら全然誰にも何のこと言わないんです
だからいい人間というのは
人に迷惑をかけない 人に対して恨み憎しみを持たない
まあ人が性格悪くたっても
まあしょうがないと まあそういう人々必然的にというかね
その条件によってそうなってるだけやと
だからまあいつでもまあわかりやすく言えば
こう 何て言いますか このすごい柔軟性
柔軟性っていうのは寛容というかね
寛容っていうことはよく出てきますね
寛容的で優柔不断ということでは意味がないんですね
寛容的ですが しっかりしている
そこら辺はすごい理解しにくいと思いますよ
柔軟性あるんだけど 曖昧というわけでもないんです
逆に今この苦しい状態の中で頑張るぞとやると
これもまた間違いなんですよね
うーん とにかく相手に対して親切に優しくいることです
慈しみ そこ そこでやってみてください
どうもありがとうございます
あの前のほうの男性 今日先ほどなんか手を挙げていた方でした
はい  悪い性格の人が自分の近くにいて
その人とどうしても付き合わなければいけない時に
その人の性格を変えたいなと思った時
どういった手立てがあるんでしょうか
それで早いのは自分がその性格を気にしないんだよということなんです
人はそう簡単に変えません
自分には自分を簡単に変えられますかね
どうですか？でしょ 自分に自分のことも簡単に変えられないのに
人のことを変えられるということ
これは無理な話です 成り立たないんです
不可能です だから自分が
まああまり気にしないことにすると
心の中には入れませんと
ということしか方法ないです
同じこと 私に同じことですよ
いろいろいますけど もう変えられないと言ってますから
自分が影響を受けないようにする
だから本当は世の中で悪い人がいるということは
私にとって問題ないんですよ
私がその影響を受けるんだから問題なんです
でしょ 世の中でいっぱい良い人間いるでしょうに
悪い人間一人しかいない
何人いるんですか？あんたに
え？何人いる？ん？あんた知ってる人々の中で
数えたことないですけど
うん 大体でいいんです
じゃあ数えてみてください
悪いあなた付き合ってる？よく知ってるね
人々の首ぐらいは数えられますよ
大体はね その中で悪い人間何人いるかというと少ないと思います
それで悪い人間がいて
そのどうしてもその人と一緒にいなくちゃいけないんだから困ってるんだという場合は
あなたにとっては悪い人間
まあ一応仮に数字言います
悪い人間二人がいる 他の人間は十五人ぐらいいる
あんた人から影響を受けるならば
十五人の影響を受けた方がすごい
抜群にあれは二つはもう全然へっちゃらになるはずなんですよ
十七人から影響を受けてますから
二人が悪いと全然もう計算にもならない
それはカットできます
だから世の中では良い人間もいる
悪い人間もいる 私には関係ない
しかし 私は影響を受けたりするんだから関係あるんですね
それでどうもよくわかりませんだけど
悪い人間の影響はすぐ受けます
良い人間の影響はもう拒絶してもう逆らう
だから自分も本当は本来悪い人間ということなんです
だからすぐ影響を受けやすいんです
影響を受けちゃうと苦しいんですよ
それに怒ってあいつを直してやりたいなと思って
それすごい悪思考なんです
それも 良い人間ならすぐもう良い人間の影響を受けます
悪人になっても あ そう
じゃあ頑張ってくださいということで終わっちゃうんです
そういうことで 東京っていうのは大都会でね
世界のものすごい巨大街でしょ？ものすごいすごい街
でもドブネズミはもうそういう高層ビルのことも知らないしね
あのモノレールのことも知らない
新幹線のことも知らないし
ドブネズミは自分たちの世界でいるんですよ
その環境で それぞれ自分に適した
例えば東京みたいな巨大街で住んでいる我々は自分に適した環境で生きているんです
東京全体的に知ってるわけじゃないんです
贅沢的にといえば むちゃくちゃ
東京っていうのはすごい贅沢なとこあるんですけど
金もない我々は知りませんと
しかし むちゃ金ある人々はそういうところは知ってますけど
そこら辺にいるコンビニのところやらね
24時間食べ物作って売ってる店とかね
あのこっちのそばにある
何でしたっけ あの弁当屋さんもいますけど
なんと名前忘れちゃった
え？オリジン弁当とか知りません
あることさえもね 金持ちは
オリジン弁当何やと だからそれぞれ自分に適した環境で生きてるんです
飲み屋さんに行って 何のことなく 1時間 2時間いてね
2  30万払っちゃう人もいるでしょうに
1ヶ月間生活してもそれぐらいお金かからない
お金ないんだからね 人もいるし
それぞれ自分に適した環境にいます
それは経済的なことだから分かりやすいでしょ
性格的も同じくなっちゃうんですよ
だから私は答えだけ 私はどうすればと
私はやっぱり影響を受けないようにした方がいいんだ
良い人間の影響を受けてみてください
友達が 4人がいて 一人が勉強嫌いで遊び好きで
3人が真面目に勉強する
自分が勉強嫌いな人のせいで勉強できなかったというと
もう初めからこの人は勉強嫌いということなんです
とにかく良い人の影響は受けてもよろしい
悪い人の影響は受けない方がよろしいということなんです
人に迷惑かけないでください
直してやるとかね それはとんでもないことなんです
できないしね そういうこと
頑張ってください  先生
ドッカクブッタいたという説法なさらなかったそうですが
それはその周辺というのは幸せだったんですか？ うん
どういう意味？ ドッカクブッタのいた場所というのは幸福な場所だった
だからドッカクブッタ現れるということは
やっぱり全体的な社会は哲学的にすごい人生について考える環境じゃないとね
俗世間のことばっかしに人生終わる環境ではね
仕事で精いっぱいの環境ではね
現れません だから余裕があって
経済的にも問題がなく
みんなそれなりの豊かできている環境で
まあ食べるものといっても簡単に手に入るわっていうね
めちゃくちゃ苦労しなくてもいいんだっていう社会では
みんな生きることは何やと再びなおさら考えちゃうんですよ
やはりそういうふうな
この思想発展している時期になってくると
じゃあ真理発見しようではないかと一人で頑張っている人々は現れてきて
ドッカクブッタになる可能性はあります
だから周りはそれなりに立派な人間でいたっていうふうに
ドッカクブッタたちにもやっぱりお布施をしたりとかね
尊敬したり 大事に思ったりする社会でしたからね
仙人たちだ 仙人たちだ
だからあまり立ち触ってはいけませんだとかね
みんな思っていたしね
尊敬はしていたし しかし本人は何も喋れました
何も喋らなくても あんた方は説法しないんだからご飯はあげませんよってことはないんです
素晴らしい方々やと 言葉を超えてますと
だから知っていたみたいですよ
だから言葉で語れない境地に達しているんだと
だから教えてくれと 語れないものは語れないんだからね
うん